[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever we won't
and Gio was topping me I love it [ __ ]
awesome record is that the until you
guys always do he changes I found one
for weekend scramble the thing you lost
it no it they play it oh they do man how
the hell you been I've been seen you in
like what eight years now [ __ ] 71 I
really haven't seen I thought yeah I was
like where did Joe go I've run into Bart
once in a while every two years I think
do you not like me or some no I'll be
dude you've been birthing babies so you
know I've seen you guys together all the
time right you probably see their
Instagram no I don't know I feel like I
was kind of butthurt because I would
watch these and then all these people in
the youtube world of our era would show
up and I'm like that was from that era -
well obviously didn't watch them that
much because you know what Joe Molly was
I turn it off soon as I realized I'm not
sitting in one of those seats I just
turn it off I'm like okay that's not me
alright whatever but it's quiet are you
gonna watch all of you that you've been
and then I besought like I felt Claire I
was like okay Clara's here does it
really yeah that was like four years ago
you've been salty for a minute No
I mean nah because I'm just like yo
what's good I haven't gotten a response
barn it's me I think barrio is only one
that hit me up like on a DM or something
randomly if he sees like an IG story I I
respond to your tweets that but you're
not talking to me to write and win
tonight when you tweet some [ __ ] I write
I ride in the car you have replied to me
one time sometimes yeah this has been
like a one-way friendship you know that
I like I reply to your stories and [ __ ]
but now I just realize you don't even
follow me ever since you became a very
popular rapper and then you left the
underground scene something change man
of all you guys or far more popular than
me that's why I felt like the least
popular one is the one who's you know
yeah you guys gonna have to reach out to
me no you know so that's how it works
like real time no it was a popularity
contest right now it looks like you guys
left me alright it doesn't look like I
let you guys you're the one that way to
Korea oh yeah
hold he was there like two weeks the
quick trip I didn't move there like I
didn't live there well sources has told
me that you went to Korea to pursue a
kpop career I know right I'm from the
[ __ ] streets owe me but I don't
remember that's why honest truth if I
did I tell you who but not I someone
told me that you went to create a
[ __ ] pursue music out there oh no
music out there but you just wait to go
eat bill visit family and hang out I go
hang out there once twice a year you
know cuz I like it there it's nice how
do I got a career I've been there twice
like you hung out and kicked it and
everything look the second time now is
pretty dull we were tonight Inchon was
it worth like everyone's be seen that's
like the airport there's a sea yeah
first time Bart when he got his ball
scrubbed the second time he saw my dick
oh you guys went to that little Osama
spots yeah the UH like what's their
version of we spot like the biggest no
that's like that's tracking spot again
dragon oh yeah yeah I've been there
Dragon's Den that sounds like a brothel
dude is it
no it's a Korean spa that's when you
take your friendship to the next level
you go to bathhouses see each other's
nuts and you're like to see now we're
friends are you down to see our our
dicks the whole I'd be scared around for
cuz he's like willingly final mmm
Steve's dick
he's our we're like is this a
traditional thing and just like yeah it
is it's some guy the size like no it's
nice like I busted a boy out of the bath
house like you think you didn't tell you
there's a there's a there's a gay meet
up dude the bathhouse we're like
everyone's naked you know and it's like
a traditional [ __ ] with your homies and
you're naked yeah it's a giant jacuzzi
everyone just hanging out it's like a
Jacuzzi she's never even seen of that
I'll be the guy there we're in like
brightly-colored [ __ ] swim trunks you
can't you're gonna get yelled at by all
women roll bro women in Korea dude it's
a cup thing I'm not from America - so
it's not like a super comfortable
situation for me to buy I have done it
you know and like I can't imagine you
know other men you know what the
funniest thing is when I see these
really tough tattooed up guys that are
really bashful in the spa like though
everyone else doesn't care but they're
like really like yeah they're the ones
weren't there the weird ones were in
swimming trunks we get ones naked macho
guy with tattoos all over the [ __ ]
comfortable cuz it's like a traditional
thing but I don't want to be the cop
from Koreatown I don't want to be in the
bathhouse and homey some guys like there
you go that's a reason I'm the engine
there's times that I don't want people
to recognize me fancy me naked all the
time
I don't want a fan like that's a bank
teller recognizing be knowing my
financial situation I don't want to I
don't want that you know like I'm like
Cassie [ __ ] okay
it's good-looking to my account and [ __ ]
like I don't like that I just like
private moments you know you don't want
why I get a private banker what a
private thing I don't have a private
Baker
that's a Bolognese Bolognese [ __ ] wait
do you have a private banker [ __ ]
private think you have a banker you
could text well I mean yeah seven emojis
- and then it
majority but majority of this stuff you
could do online I mean like you don't
even have to go in the bank anymore that
is a good point unless you need only
unless you need to get cash then you
just get to go to the ATM you work out a
bank on the [ __ ] part - no I'm just
saying if you want to avoid human
contact there where there is a will
there is a way that's true now you take
pictures of checks and [ __ ] yeah it's
bring fun there's times you have to go
in the bank though like when there's
time I'm just trying to help you to
avoid moments shows like let me help you
man let me like to get your financial
situation right I get excited about that
[ __ ] dude I hope they're [ __ ] PR debt
I help people make money man [ __ ] that
that's my [ __ ] dude back in the day with
the suit with the questions over I mean
I think Bill Nighy kind of took his
whole image I bet you he sees Bill Nye
on TV and he's like in a dark basement
and he sees like the blue the blue of
the TV and he's here's Bill Nye in there
and he throws a milkshake and he's like
god damn you bill nye made me happy use
let me help you get money I'm like okay
let's get money together you should get
a show going on it's like where are they
now and then it's like all the
infomercial people they did one on him
though right I think needed advice news
on the guy he's rich he's rich as [ __ ]
William Lascaux was this gammy everyone
around I think so yeah
no you just took facts of like loopholes
and stuff in this system to actually get
money grants loans all the [ __ ] yeah
yeah sold a book about down that's the
way to wait for again it was a scam yeah
just have to ill suits no you make it
when you have a book up exactly or
you're an expert at something when you
have a book out what am I an expert at
kids no you know who's still making
[ __ ] commercials and [ __ ] the your
mattress is free dude oh man 30 years ya
know the GoSee hell guy remember that
guy go see how busting out oh yeah I
don't know he like he [ __ ] it was a
[ __ ] countless the mattress is local
too right yeah yeah yeah
this is all for the west coast nobody
knows all about the Men's Wearhouse you
like the way you look well that went
viral I think cuz everyone's like this
guy's sucks yeah what Alan is not local
right Alan nationwide nationwide no no
no the East Coast people like I haven't
seen commercials in a minute though man
that's the only reason why we have cable
cuz home over here I love commercials I
miss them no silver shows have gotten
drastic with the volume level change
thing though have you noticed that oh
yeah well it's been a problem for a long
time yeah when they go from a TV show to
commercial all the sort of volume
switches loudest [ __ ] and it's true what
the [ __ ] they do now purpose because
they want to like wake you up to watch
the [ __ ] commercial crazy because I
was just over their house and I saw some
commercials and they actually make the
commercials look like YouTube videos
alright some of them do yeah I never see
you anymore because I don't watch TV but
only during football season oi see ads
and then I see everyone watching TV yeah
they are yeah
I don't watch as much stuff on TV I [ __ ]
I just flipped it's a good place this
flip do stuff I do miss like if you're
on like a UH you know Apple what's that
bucks think Apple TV all that stuff like
you can't really like flip through stuff
that's why I've missed that I missed
like flipping through TVs not a brain
power dude i sat there and and spent
over 30 minutes strategizing what show
I'm gonna watch we're on Apple TV yeah
for Netflix right you like this I'm Azad
and with
that's unsafe but it's so it crazy how
many titles they have and you can't find
a goddamn thing to watch on that [ __ ]
like more stress you have cuz you're
just like I don't know what if I pick
the wrong one now everyone has a [ __ ]
Netflix comedy special they have ruined
what comedy specials control they're the
specialty of that is pretty gone oh my
god when everybody in the world has one
it's like it's not special it's not
special anymore
also I love the shitty versions of like
blockbuster films like to have like
Jurassic land yeah the city versions of
like the low-budget versions of all the
blacklist have you noticed that they
have those like it's like every disaster
movie you continually have yeah hey you
know tsunami like whatever dude
skyscraper looks like a [ __ ]
low-budget one of those movie what is
Dwayne the rock doing man
he's ruining now he has the recipe to be
successful dude any producers I'm sure
betcha skyscrapers gonna be lit bro no
way bro looks like [ __ ] dude movie
premise it's like he's the guy that
designed the building or something and
he's the only one that knows the way out
it goes in flames or some [ __ ] yeah I
don't know what it is you know trying to
collab movie the last 10 movies are
trying to collapse baby watches a china
clock yeah it is China a China this has
that crazy budget they have you know so
people are like okay we'll make a movie
with you cuz they got the budget and
even if it's shitty they're just like we
still get the paid everything now that
Hollywood's making is like let me be
[ __ ] a look at Chinese dick or Marvel
[ __ ] that's a good way to put it right
there that case they can barely sell it
to China which is super weird or at
least in Star Wars okay might throw
those numbers to you or we might look at
Chinese big want to like it so guys the
money's right
the good idea they dude that rampage
movie I was like what the [ __ ] is this
so that's that seemed like kind of like
one of those movies to try it China
budget movie the Chinese like I want to
know I need I need to make a make a
Chinese friend that's not like one that
escaped China you know I mean like I got
too many Chinese [ __ ] backstabber
friends you know I got I've got more my
Chinese friends are broke
like I need to make the rich Chinese
friends because I'm saying all of our
Chinese friends are the ones that ran
away from China too early they gave up
this communist ass place and now they're
laughing like we don't have morale but
we have money and I always have a theory
about like the the the like the Asian
cats who came here and then like that
the Asian people here who moved back to
Asia like we send the shittiest versions
of shitty citizens of each state to each
other state oh yeah that's true I mean
like if I'm in Cape Town and I met a
boba shop getting like the waitresses
and they were like the fob wages is like
the shittiest service like it's not the
stupidest [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah and it's
like the vice versa we all do like the
ex-gangster Asian boots your moves back
to Korea Japan or whatever like cuz when
I was you know I'll go eat at k-town and
I was like man Kri Kri waiters are so
mean and then I go to Korea and they're
the [ __ ] disaster they're like the
best service because they're become la
people yeah holy people are [ __ ] me
period maybe I wait people are the
meanest people on the [ __ ] just hates
la people they think we're like snobs
well the right no III think it's LA
versus Hollywood you know I mean yeah
that's Hollywood and there's LA if
you're part of the LA culture there's a
lot of culture in it yeah what people
perceive la is Hollywood that's what
they perceive right and in 99 percent of
Hollywood is not even people that were
born and raised in LA no Hollywood
people are it's just like I'm telling
Matt the mentality and more than the
region you know I mean like you walk up
to a Hollywood person you say hello and
then you've got like you know 30 seconds
to brag about the five things that
you're up to and if they're not
interesting enough it's like see you
later you're not important la is
self-absorbed you know I'm saying but I
will say like that's that's what drives
people to you know like people are like
every every artist is self-absorbed it's
one way or another you know what I mean
and like they're striving for big [ __ ]
everyone here always wants to do the big
[ __ ] you know sure they're not settling
they want like
the top time I turn it to calm and ooh
you're such a positive rapido I'm gonna
turning into Gary Vee and [ __ ] like just
come on guys yeah well you were born I
mean you're born and raised in LA yeah
well no I was born Argentina oh really
you a South America my nose weird South
American Korean because Spanish Oh
bookie not good enough that's like the
one thing I always say I don't speak no
Spanish now um yeah I mean my mom
smuggled not smuggle snuck us it me and
my little sister through the Mexican
border we crossed into the whole Mexican
border and everything well you're not
gonna hunt your sister I am yeah I'm
gonna cool Oh babies yeah she's two and
a half right now what did you think is
like everyone in entertainment that I
mean or in YouTube or whatever majority
of them are not from LA you know that's
that's the best that's the crazy thing
is like damn there's so many on local
people and in everyone that's making
comments about LA though that come here
don't like it all that stuff you're not
running into LA people you're running
into people from home whatever state
that came here wanted to be famous that
wanted to do something they have no time
yeah body has a complaint about each
other like LA natives hate they're like
stop stop coming into LA all these
people I can't even say that we just too
big that's I'm saying I'm just like bro
like it's it that makes la great in that
sense there's all these people from all
over like really you know I mean that's
the identity in itself now at this point
you could imagine if all the actors if
you haven't booked anything in a year
you have to leave away I'll be awesome
right eyeball dude we can't [ __ ] go
please I could come see you guys in 15
minutes it's no I love that if you
haven't booked anything into here you
gotta get the [ __ ] just do it until you
booked something man sorry that's the
game oh that's what happens in agency
servers up the restaurants they're all
gone you know what but then but then the
servers that are there would be getting
paid way more money all true how nice
would that be for that maybe yeah
well I haven't gotten booked for [ __ ] so
I might get kicked the [ __ ] day there's
many people who just live in LA and they
don't want to be an actor yeah and
that's great and they're not fake it is
refreshing nowadays when you meet people
that aren't in the whole hashtag mullet
I mean the slash generation of like I do
this I do that I just like you know when
you meet somebody like I'm gonna I just
do this it's like I like that you know I
mean it's like refreshing like that's
dope
that's why I like these guys we have
when I'm talking about [ __ ] YouTube
yep we're talking about how [ __ ]
stupid it is basically at this point we
do like you know how I like that asian
conversation always is like oh they
always wanted us to be doctors and
lawyers and now we can be entertainers
I'm like I think we need to go back to
the doctor and lawyer like we need more
doctors and lawyers now of a good like
we don't need another youtuber or a net
are you gonna lead the way are you gonna
be the first doctor named um yeah here's
my announcement I'm quitting and I'm
going to write back I'm going I'm going
to write back like I was a doctor before
I medical school if I get my insurance
paper and it says like your new
physician is doctor dumb I'm like walk
that like [ __ ] top man they'll have
the be me I'd be like well how much is
he is it much cheaper would you ought to
be operated by a guy to doctor dumb like
I mean if you can operate [ __ ] that that
means something I mean I don't you hear
about that teenager that was passing as
a doctor by like a year or something
that was pretty funny YouTube videos
heart surgery same [ __ ] whatever the
[ __ ] right you learn you learn anything
it's all what kind of doctor like so I
got a it using a doctor what is it like
[ __ ] dude I need some [ __ ] surgery I
got shot doctor you know like what kind
of what kind of doctor or dr. Dre yeah
if it's the if it's the first one where
I got a little cold
Annie doctor they just they're just a
medicine writer have a super writer damn
for all of you then
oh you [ __ ] ass medicine writers out
there [ __ ] it on the process of becoming
a doctor I even think of old rappers cuz
this is so interesting right you got
aging metal big guys you got aging rock
and roll guys everywhere right you got
like Aerosmith all like [ __ ] 90 died
I think about it all the time and I like
I like write about it and stuff too
because it's just like it's interesting
thing you know like I'm in my time just
going my thirties now so it's like dirty
is like 40 50 and rap years you know
because it's like a YouTube and then it
made fun of Moby he was like you're 30
years old it's over let go kill yourself
basically remember that yeah now he's
like hitting 40 you know I'm saying he's
like closer to 50 is important that's
upset it's like that it's crazy cuz it's
such a youth driven industry it's like a
young person's thing you know so it's
weird when you turn hold and you rat
you're still rapping about like hella
young [ __ ] like Snoop Dogg not snoop I
think Snoopy wanted and that embraced
his aging you know I mean he goes by
uncle snoop for like the last 15 you
know I mean like yeah that could be a
nephew like he feels like I don't cool
you know I'm not like Method Man Redman
and like earlier I'm not like 60 now G
older but they still have I mean the
thing is those lot of some older rappers
are like they've aged well where they
feel like you know they've embraced
getting old like jay-z oh yeah he like
he makes grown rap you know you know
that dog crack so they don't look that
that's true like I saw Beastie Boys and
I was like damn
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]